entre los escombros este residente local
Busca cualquier señal de vida
hasta que un débil grito se logra oír
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como Ven aquí hay un cadáver
está muerto y nadie lo ha sacado
y se oye la voz de una mujer desde abajo
aquí en el sur la gente espera con
angustia Que lleguen organismos de
Socorro para sacar a más personas de
entre las montañas de escombros
los oídos están pidiendo ayuda piensa
rescatados no podemos rescatarlos como
podemos rescatarlos
nadie ha venido desde esta mañana nadie
no tenemos a nadie miren a su alrededor
mire
dada la magnitud de la catástrofe los
servicios de emergencia están
desbordados y sacar de los escombros a
los sobrevivientes es una carrera
contrarreloj miles de edificios se
derrumbaron a lo largo del día por las
ondas de un terremoto de magnitud 7,8 y
unas horas más tarde una segunda
sacudida casi tan potente como la
inicial se produjo a más de 100
kilómetros de distancia extendiendo aún
más la magnitud de los daños los
temblores provocaron que miles de
personas quedaran atrapadas bajo las
ruinas que más edificios se derrumbaran
y que decenas de personas se refugiaran
donde fuera posible el presidente
turcoan ha declarado 7 días de luto
nacional mientras llegan equipos de
ayuda de todo el mundo incluida la otan
y países de la Unión Europea